I'm happy to be joined by jeff gerstmann
from the Giant Bomb black car hello and
if I having a van oord of GameSpot to
talk about what's already come out I
guess q1 is kind of done and dusted
we've closed the doors on the first
quarter of the year yeah I'm gonna get
into the sales figures and stuff later
on but first of all what's been your
favorite game of the past 33 a half
months or so yeah I don't know it's uh
there's been some good stuff nothing
that is like just straight up like all
this this is definitely the greatest
game yeah i'm playing trials fusion even
though i think it's not as good as the
previous trials game like the
leaderboard stuff is still good enough
infamous was fun but you know I kind of
blew through in a day what about tying
to fault you played a lot of that I did
I you know I played a lot of titanfall
right around release and then I probably
in a plane about 25 hours of it and I
it's really well made but you know like
they announced like that deal seems like
odd yeah you know don't care I know that
I it's weird I feel like this is the
first titanfall conversation I've had
with anyone in about a month orale yeah
it's sold 300 thousand or so I'm xbox
one at about a hundred thousand on xbox
360 I find that number weird I thought
it was going to sell way more on the
oval how do you I mean how do you even
have a number for xbox 360 they put that
out yeah I saw it on an article
somewhere because then I came out in
April so the March NPD's wouldn't say
anything about ours so maybe you think
of PC mmm or maybe I made it up maybe
either way maybe a put out numbers who
knows huh so do you think that game has
been successful enough for them do you
think it was Morse it was most important
as a software sale or was it as a reason
to get people to buy xbox well I think
it actually I mean you know that that's
Microsoft's motivation on that end I
don't think that any of that actually
matters i think that they planted a very
firm flag and said titanfall is a very
big world class marquee franchise and so
when the second one comes out on all
platforms I you will already know what
this is and rush out to hopefully go buy
it you know they did they did a great
job of establishing a franchise and you
know they they made a great game you
know it is a lot of fun to play but I
just don't know how much longer I'm
going to be interested in
competitive first-person shooters oh
just full stop yeah you know you know
you look at kind of what call of duty
the trend of Call of Duty for the past
couple years like I mean now we'd like
ghosts for ghosts Activision is just
sending out desperation emails all the
time they're like do you want to buy a
snoop dogg announcer pack or I mean
we've got weed Leafs you can put on your
gun and now we're selling them is who
like and and then they're like whatever
service sends it like you got eight
headshots that last round that's more
than you've ever got I'm like I haven't
played this game in four months I don't
know what it send you emails yeah oh god
the number of things they've turned on
for call of duty and it to remind you
that it exists and that maybe you
accidentally bought it is a pretty clear
sign that things are maybe not going
their way so you think maybe time fall
is tied itself onto a genre that sort of
already on a downward seems like what
could they do with a titanfall 2 that
would make you feel compelled to play it
I think you know I think it did a lot of
it stems from my problems with kind of
the first titanfall was that a lot of
the gear felt uninteresting and sort of
meaningless mmm the you know granted I
tend to kind of play those games a very
specific way but I feel like everyone's
probably that way but a lot of those
items just didn't seem useful yeah you
know they had like what was one of the
perks like oh the ice pick the the
hacking thing happens faster which you
never use you never hack stuff like who
cares like that's all stuff that at some
point you're like they have another mode
plans yeah do they have some other stuff
and you know they'll put up their maps
and modes and stuff for this one but I
think generally let that game is largely
successful because it did establish a
franchise and gives them like a good
spot to launch off yeah whether they
want to build a campaign which you know
I don't know that it necessarily do or
or really kind of figure out what are
the ways to actually blow out that
combat and whether it's like is it just
more higher player counter or whatever
all right stepping away from the
consoles for a second then your favorite
game of the year dark souls 2 probably
so far although I got to give a shout
out to the wolf among us which I I know
I'm not a big fan of The Walking Dead
universe you know I never really cared
about the games that much I didn't care
about the world
though it's funny though the wolf among
us was the world was new to me I'd now
but I didn't read fables until I played
the first episode and so I played the
first episode and then I I ran out and
grabbed fables volumes and started
reading them voraciously and now I think
that universe is really awesome actually
and the third episode in particular the
one that the one that just came out is
is fantastic and I actually would rather
you know play those games eight days a
week over or the walking dead there's
that's one of three different one of
those sort of i don't what did what do
we call is no adventure it's just
chapter because the episodes all known i
started at a specific telltale style to
which i actually can't stand really like
the the gameplay stuff like especially
the way they handle action like that
first episode of wolf among us were
there like now getting a fist fight
you're like right this is like
everything I hated about the walking
dead good like is it it's it's starting
to get stale I mean already you know you
know you go from walking dead getting
game of the year awards from different
places right you know already we sort of
know more or less how things are going
to go it's becoming more tries what
every single about these games I mean
maybe it's just a weird bubble that that
I live in these days but it feels like
no one is talking about the walk yeah
season yeah but then you see always see
the numbers to comment especially for
stuff like ipad and suddenly you realize
there's the massive yeah i'm sure ladies
games which one of the things we're like
you know no one talks about Skylanders
anymore i but it's quietly out there
making a zillion dollars and and all
that stuff where it's just they build
their fan base and cater to that fan
base and they're not necessarily pulling
people yeah anymore we're not the
conversations were involved in any way
yeah what about broken age then sort of
you know another one of those adventure
games being released in two parts but
very different in terms of gameplay to
the other two I'll leave this one is
Jeff because I didn't actually play
bribed a bunch so it's a casualty of
telltale over saturating the adventure
game genre you know what it's a I played
a little bit of broken age and thought
it was incredibly well-made yeah and had
zero desire to continue playing it did
you complete us nope now I think even
the short first episode like it was just
like ya know this is this is all really
well-made maybe i'll get back to it
someday and yeah I just you know I liked
season one of Sam and Max will tell tale
put that out where I was great and then
kind of everything after that's been
like
you know maybe adventure games really
did go away for a reason I find I I did
the same thing I play probably with two
hours of that never got to the end of it
and the thing that irked me was knowing
that it when I continue playing I'd
never finish it that I have to wait and
there's the thing that annoyed me about
the way I play The Walking Dead games
was I waited for everything to come back
yeah I'll try to keep away from spoilers
and then just blow through one go a
satellite going through it in the
episodic style because I don't really
watch much television right so for me
this sort of takes that place of
something for me to look forward to you
know when i'm in a month or so when the
next installment comes out I can sort of
ruminate on what I think might happen
sure what this means or what that means
that's what about dark souls to them are
souls to a zoo is a really great game
and I I feel sort of bad that it you
know the kerfuffle around the visuals
and how it didn't look as good as the
the first showings of the game and how
the lighting model had changed things
like that I felt like I mean that's only
like every video game ever released so
you can say oh they put out a trailer
that was like their ambitions for the
game and then the realities of
developing for old ass console hardware
hitam yep weird yeah and and it's too
bad because the game is really excellent
its own right I I still I still maintain
that Dark Souls the original is very
special and I don't think dark souls 2
really captured all of that but i think
it's i think it's still awesome that has
this big world that i loved exploring
and you know i'm i'm still in it i'm
still playing the pc version now going
through and hopefully finish for a
second time and see how that goes a
third time that affords all their bosses
that i missed the first time oh and
there's a little air a whole little area
that I never even saw that I didn't even
know existed until I started playing the
pc version like what's down there and I
drop down and suddenly there's this
whole thing I've never seen and there's
a boss in there and and so on and so
forth so that and to me that's the
wonder of of dark souls is that there's
there's so much out there to to take in
and it's such a big game in such a
difficult game but when i was looking at
through all the sort of titles that came
out in the past three or four months the
amount of like smaller experience like
nidhogg jazzpunk em like that like oh
jazzpunk is amazing there's so many of
those that have loved
not so much what a great game are you
being sarcastic oh I'm not worried
actually that's how do you think that
God about yes yes I got freaked out
about three levels damage isn't just I
mean there's more like for whatever
there's just Oh take care of it is it so
I've only been in this industry a couple
of years you guys been around a lot
longer and there seems to be that whole
you know split between that whatever is
the big mainstream game and then your
indie stuff is it that the middle tier
games have disappeared because when I
was looking through the list of what's
come out it seems to be either go big or
go home and then these kind of scary the
bigger titles are just getting bigger
and more they become more risk-averse as
a result so you know that's why you have
things like yeah we're gonna make
another Gears of War I guess cuz that's
an established franchise that they can
justify spending a bunch of money on and
then you know your publishers like THQ
and Midway don't exist anymore and you
know you have even the the publishers
that we still think of is like smaller
publishers like I've my like a warner or
yeah even even Ubisoft some extent I
stole for whatever reason think it was
like and they're not quite on the level
of like an EA or are we getting better
games out of it though and you look at
like some of the small games I totally I
think yeah we're getting more games
we're getting riskier games out of the
smaller and and and it's way more
exciting you know if you think about it
the what we're losing out on are a lot
of mid to your games that you know you
would have some really heartwarming
interesting things like you know like
alter echo yeah you know next in these
yeah blitz League or you know just
psyops you know we're data you
interesting kind of genre titles that
don't necessarily exist in that way
anymore it's where thing about who's in
that space now and I keep thinking that
I'll ined and yeah I can't come up with
anything else up right above my head of
whom really sits in how about sneezing
Stein oh yeah yes on is kind of the
ultimate like they're just putting out a
shooter I don't know kind of game like
you look at it and you're like all right
go with God I guess I feel like
whoever's making their trailers is doing
a really good job of selling a game that
maybe isn't as good as what the trailers
I don't know I look at the date they
seem compelling the trailers but then I
think about what that game is it's a
single player of a tower shooting game a
bit killing our teaser they go
done that like yeah and you think about
it you know like what what is what is
wolfenstein now you know the people of
killing Nazis yeah they will always love
her as much as I love it like you know
you don't get a lot of games that have
it that feature that as a core element
and so maybe this return to Nazi murder
will will get people back on board or
something but I just kind of look at it
like I you know I kind of liked the the
last Wolfenstein return uh yeah I think
return was lost for escape it was just
referenced I know as it was just way to
say yeah that's right if they're reboot
or mater I thought that was that was a
good ambitious weird thing but human
Stein all right well talk about 83 in a
second all the games coming up first of
all I want to quickly talk about at ps4
and xbox one first three months Jeff
first of all which do you think has had
the best and maybe not necessarily in
terms of sales in terms of what it
delivers to consumers which is the best
one do you think at this stage it's ps4
I mean it's a hundred hours cheaper it
has most of the same games and they
often look better like that's not even a
question you know it's a it's it's
pretty undeniable at this point that the
ps4 is pulled ahead for a reason you
know it's definitely not over for the
xbox one you know I think some of the
stuff that the Xbox one has exclusively
I think it is interesting and fun you
know titan falls in a hell of a game
yeah i'll give you a ride a qatari
exclusive of that it looks on paper it
looks like some bigger exclusive so what
is it about the playstation 4 is it is
it really like this I think I just don't
care about exclusives because I own both
systems right that's that's not really a
meaningful factor to me it's more just
like you know okay if we really think
about it the vast majority of games will
be available on both platforms yeah or
I'm probably on a PC as well right yeah
but if we're just talking about consoles
and trying to actually compare them
you've got a cheaper more powerful
console that has you know ninety percent
the same games and so so even in this
case where I don't particularly like
Sony's first party development all that
much when I compare it to most of
Microsoft's tongue just franchise for
franchise I mean it's the ps4 is the
console right now we were having this
discussion last year we probably would
have mentioned another company as well
and Nintendo today announced that
they're not going to happen
press conference again at e3 this year
which just means that they're going to
do the wrong thing on the side probably
yeah what do you think about the future
of the Wii U is it just are we done and
dusted with that at the moment so I
think I mean you know that they're
always going to be one hit away right
you know they're just if they can but is
that he getting further and further away
I just I think it's it's you know the
the thing that they run into well the
thing I think about it's like are they
actually capable of making that game
anymore right you know isn't intento
still Nintendo and you look at the games
they're putting out like they're fine
you know if that's your looking for you
know they had a some fake thing where
it's like oh the Reggie mech is taking
over a Nintendo's Twitter account today
and right one of the things this is
their year of the region 4 2014 yeah one
of the things they tweeted was there
will be no urban champion to okay like
yeah of course cuz why do anything risky
that might be weird and interested in a
row ahead and just putting out the same
crap everyone's working out so well not
that i really wanted urban champion to
but that would be something you'd look
at god huh well someone's crazy over
there good but instead they can't even
do that yep so yeah look at 43 then
what's your most anticipated game i'm
just look I had to look to see what it
was of the order of course are probably
going to show more of I guess maker
solid five kendo might show that Zelda
that they might have showed last year
the tekmoto a one is that as actual
dynasty warriors Zelda game oh really
yeah I mean it's great the the rumor
going around is resident evil 7 ok be
shown so another crisis 3 it will
probably not in favor of a resonable 7
certainly but are you saying Capcom
still makes video games no it's it's
interesting though because it's either
it's their chance to prove that they
know that that they've still got it when
it comes to resident evil but it could
also just be another you know just like
point and laugh moment from from the
sidelines at this stage like let's hope
that they they've learned their lessons
from so what is it you get excited about
for at e3 surly it's like software
enhancements is it stuffed and that
probably nobody knows about is that what
we're like the question mark is why
we're that's always my favorite thing
about already know what I'm excited it
III do I yeah all right let's leave it
at
Jeff chrisman thanks very much going on
kevin was inside baseball stuff going on
man in sideways at the Guinness yeah
yeah Guinness video game I thought to be
something I get excited about thanks
very much chance for coming on as ever I
will be back after a quick